[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and like a bad out of
hell castlevania has returned
it's a fantastic finale that has a lot
to sink your teeth into and throughout
this video we'll be recapping season 4
its ending and talking about our
thoughts on it as a whole
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then i
highly recommend that you check out now
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
worth rising from the dead 4.
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into castlevania
season 4.
okay so the finale has a lot at stake
not only does it wrap up the show as a
whole in outstanding fashion
but it also ties into the mythos of
dracula and sets up several potential
spin-offs
i'm going to be recapping big chunks of
the plot and discussing how they lay the
groundwork for the future
but time codes will be linked below if
you want to skip ahead to a certain
section
now season 3 ended with a lot of things
up in the air including the impending
vampire war between carmilla and isaac's
forces
with her sister lenore she managed to
manipulate hector into using his forge
master abilities
which he planned on utilizing in order
to build an empire alucard went from
desperate
lonely man to the new dracula and trevor
and cipher met with a time traveler
named count saint-germain
jermaine was searching for his wife and
he ended up journeying through the
infinite corridor
at the end of the series season 4 picks
up a couple of weeks after the events of
the prior entry
and many of the characters in it have
become warped because of the things that
played out in it
trevor and scifir wandered throughout
the land for weeks on end
battling evil forces still down for the
count like a bad boxer
they unearth a murder plot which
involves killing people on mass to bring
dracula back
and it's one of the more bloodiest
season intros that we've had so far
it's clear that the pair are still in
shock over what they witnessed in
lindenfeld
and the events of this have changed
their perspective on life
cypher even says [ __ ] now which oh how
things have
changed they believed that everything
would be over after killing dracula
but they're now spending the rest of
their lives stopping people from
resurrecting him
which of course they're not very vlad
about
i'm sorry that that was terrible now in
this series
trevor acquires a specialized dagger
that is powerful enough to stop death
itself
and we'll talk about how this culminates
later on in the video
however putting a hold to the
resurrection of dracula
very much becomes their arc in the
season and the driving force in their
lives
initially belmont is scorned by this
burden and he believes that it has
stripped his lifeable meaning
however it's through this final season
he realizes that simply isn't the case
because of this task before him he
finally finds something that is greater
than himself
and is worth fighting for it's given his
life a purpose beyond what he initially
thought
and it sort of brings everything full
circle for the character
we'll talk about his fate later on but
along the way we are introduced to vani
who becomes a big character in the
series that everyone has been
dying to meet eh now he reaches out to
isaac
who remains one of the most interesting
characters in the entire show
he debates philosophy with his own ranks
and discusses his own dichotomy
isaac and his forces are metaphorically
hammers as they can be used as weapons
of destruction
however they can also be used to
construct and build something new
though revenge still drives him he very
much wants to build a better world in
the end
this motif very much speaks to the
opening episodes of season four
and when we're not dealing with action
what we get are highly introspective
looks with the characters
who regularly cross-examine what they've
been through what it has cost
and why it has changed them isaac's
opposite is of course hector
who is in a much better position than he
was in the last season
whereas he was a prisoner in that he's
now got free reign of carmilla's castle
and her wine cellar his forge master
abilities are very
important but carmilla knows he's up to
something and he wanders throughout the
castle
planting coins however he does start to
transform the dead
ultimately to fighting carmilla's war
unfortunately though
all this waiting in futility makes his
sisters start to become disillusioned
with her plans
striga even calls the forces their
fighting livestock
and she very much views her sending her
undead stock i think it is
as a waste of energy never before has a
show managed to capture the boredom that
would come with immortality
and having all the time in the world
gives them time to question the point of
their war
they're fighting over pointless farmland
and much like trevor and cypher
initially did
they believe that they're stuck in a
never-ending cycle elsewhere alucard
though cut off from humanity
gets another chance at life when a
villager known as greta reaches out to
him
to come and save her home this gives him
a new purpose in life
and he utters the line i'm turning into
belmont which
ultimately hints to him getting another
life with a new partner
finding a purpose is very much what
drives every character in the show
and whether it's the belmonts looking
for a reason behind all the killing
they're doing
alucard protecting the people of dynasty
carmilla's sisters seeing the futility
of war
or isaac wanting to build a better
future each character
is trying to find a reason for their
existence now nowhere is this
represented more than in bill nye he
said germain
who is desperately searching for his
wife he reappears in dynasty
and we recount how he met his lover and
what happened to him after the events of
season three
in the infinite corridor he found
himself unable to control his
destination
and eventually he entered the library
only to find that his love had moved on
he does however come across an apparent
alchemist who tells him that he must
sacrifice everything he believes in
in order to get his love back we learned
that he was actually in contact with
barney
and though he gives him little respect
like most of the characters in the show
they want the same thing many of the
massacres that trevor and cypher come
across were actually caused by him
and it was saint-germain all along
he appears to be donning the red coat
from the game that was almost hidden
under his green
cloak in the last season and he does
start to line up more with the source
material
his purpose drives him to selfishly
commit all kinds of atrocities
and it becomes clear he's willing to do
anything to complete his goals
he suggests to ali card that in order to
gain refuge the villagers should move to
his home
which brings him closer to his endgame
elsewhere
isaac sends his forces to storm
carmilla's castle and it's here we get
something i really wasn't expecting
though he's held a vendetta against
hector he ends up sparing his life
because he has an epiphany that they
were both simply the tools of someone
else
this very much ties back to his line
about hammers and how they can be used
as both tools to build
and also destroy he sees himself as
someone wanting to become the hand that
holds the hammer
rather than the hammer itself and i
really hope that i've nailed that
metaphor
now he really does so bad now he
relinquishes control of the vampires
and thus weakens carmilla's army using
the coins that hector plays throughout
the castle
isaac creates a powerful prison to hold
carmilla in place
and the battle between the pair is
bloody and brutal she ends up destroying
herself in a last-ditch attempt to kill
the character
and promises to wait for him in hell
where she will relish torturing him for
eternity
it's a chilling way for her to go out
and probably the most badass death in
this entire season
now together moreno and striga arrive to
see their home destroyed
and thus they decide to break free of
the control that they've been subjected
to
and go somewhere else possibly a
spin-off which we'll talk about later
now for camilla's sisters
their arc was very much about breaking
free of the path that they had been
forced to walk on
this is reflected in hector and isaac
who want to break free of what was meant
for them
they decide not to resurrect dracula and
instead
isaac decides to build something
positive for the future
now whether he returns or not we don't
know but this does
juxtapose his arc in the game series as
he was used to resurrect dracula
he ended up being driven mad by this
possession and was killed in order to
free him of this torment
initially he was a very tragic character
but here it's a far more positive ending
for him
mirroring breaking free of this path we
too see it echoed in lenore's final act
she realizes that she's pretty much
lived a life of servitude
being controlled by others thus she
doesn't want to go on being constantly
kept in a cage
and decides to break free of it lenore
goes on to the balcony to watch the sun
rise
and ends her own life in a last act that
shows she found some freedom and death
it's a great scene for the character and
a tear-jerking way to end her journey
now the characters who realize they
should focus on their lives
instead of bringing back the dead have a
far more positive outcome
and we head into the final arc of the
season with dracula's resurrection
taking the main focal point varney
travels to find a mirror that will
transport him to where dracula was
killed
and this is buried in the caverns of a
city that was attacked by the character
he runs into trevor and cipher along the
way who travel with him to the location
here we catch san germain attempting to
pull dracula and lisa out of hell
and he wishes to fuse their salts into a
hermaphrodite body
using his alchemy which will create a
divine new being powerful enough to
control the infinite corridor with
yes it's a bit convoluted but this is
where everything comes to a head
and trevor and cypher join alikar's side
as they attempt to not only stop the
forces laying siege to the castle
but also jermaine's plans it's an
incredible way to close out the season
finale
and they definitely saved the best for
last in terms of action
it's rather a show manages to stick the
landing in this day and age
but castlevania completely knocks it out
of the park
in these final moments in the basement
bonnie reveals that he's been
manipulating things from the shadows
and not only was he the alchemist that
jermaine met in the library
but also death itself though many
cultures believe the entity to be
well just the grim reaper death is
actually a vampire creature
that feasts on well death since the
beginning of time he has manipulated
worldwide events so that great losses of
life will be caused
and he has wished to bring dracula and
lisa back into this combined body
because he knows it will cause him to
become even more mad
leading to more deaths people just
aren't dying like they used to
and thus he has manipulated several of
the characters in order to achieve this
goal
so that his thirst for death can be
quenched it's a great twist that i don't
think anyone could have predicted
and it's a brilliant inclusion of a
character who has appeared in many of
the games in the series
jermaine pulls their spirits through and
into the body
which i can't really show in action
because of cartoon titties
youtube youtube just doesn't like
cartoon titties now belmont manages to
break through the barrier
and he destroys the body as well as the
gateway to hell
jermaine spots his lover through the
infinite corridor
but she closes the doorway leaving him
not only having lost her
but also himself because of what he was
willing to do the final battle finds
belmont going head-to-head with death
and using the special dagger he gained
earlier he manages to defeat the evil
entity
stabbing the creature with this not only
sucks it but also belmont into the void
and though it initially seems like he is
dead we discover that the character is
alive and that he was merely transported
through the infinite corridor
weeks later cypher goes to leave the
castle and we discover that she is
pregnant
this is likely simon who in the series
would go on to continue
their legacy of vampire hunting now
whilst this has been announced as being
the final season
deadline recently posted an article that
said netflix were eyeing some spin-off
series
that would follow different characters
feel like we need to talk about this
before diving into how the season ends
and if they go this route i can see
cipher and trevor raising their child to
become the next big protagonist in the
show's continuity
you also see ali card a man who has
found nothing but loneliness
deciding to settle down with greta and
create a village called traffic
sorry belmont it's called it's
definitely called belmont
now ali code looks happy for the first
time in a while and we learn that his
parents spirits have remained outside of
hell
and that they plan to return to their
son when the time is right
however they realize that he has gained
some closure and don't want to rob him
of this
and thus enact a slightly different plan
the pair want to move to england
namely whitby which highly ties in with
dracula lore
in bram stoker's novel this was actually
the location that the villain traveled
to
after he left transylvania i've been
there a couple of times myself
and it's got a great haunting
atmospheric cathedral at the top of the
hill
that looms over the city there's a real
atmosphere to it
and i recommend that you visit it if
you're ever able to
yes this video was sponsored by whitby
now together
they will have a life there and when the
time is right return to their sun
no doubt their legend will continue and
i can actually see the potential
spin-off series chronicling their new
life in europe
dracula finally has the woman he loved
and he's back out into the world
though we don't know exactly how they
survived it is possible that in the
destruction of death
their souls and bodies remained in the
mortal world and this is how they were
able to come back
they will reunite with alucard one day
which will likely be the culmination of
both their rock and his
in which we will be able to see what
happened after the events of this show
if they get the spin off which would we
be we better get that spin off
now whilst no spin-offs have been
announced yet as of making this video
when the show's this good it would suck
if they didn't
i'm not sure if it's the best season
just yet as i only finished it today and
haven't had time to sit with it properly
but at the very least it does feel like
the best season
as mentioned earlier it's rare that a
show can deliver a satisfying ending but
castlevania season 4
definitely does this feels like a great
conclusion to everyone's arc
and i really hope that we get some news
about the story continuing
in some form or another thank you
netflix for bringing this to the screen
and you know what to do next just give
us more
castlevania was incredible and it gets a
9 out of 10.
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the season
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the ending of resident evil 8
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over all the events in village
and talked about the final few scenes so
it's definitely worth playing out if you
want a bit more horror related video
game stuff
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul
and i'll see you next time take care
peace